bonjour pour ce nouveau numéro de
diagonale la leçon nous avons la chance
de recevoir
jean-luc chabanon maître international
et qui va me servir d'experts alors jean
luc tu as choisi une superbe partie pour
cette porte ce premier numéro
quelle est-elle donc bonjour maintenant
donc j'ai choisi la partie karpov
topalov qui s'est jouée à linares 194
donc c'est une très jolie partie c'est
une anglaise est donc ce tournoi
d'ailleurs de linares 194 a été gagné
par karpov nettement c'était donc la
période où karpov était vraiment au top
top comme si on peut on peut le dire et
donc dans cette partie nous allons voir
comment karpov puis transport
transformer un avantage stratégique avec
avec brio très bien à leurs actions en
actions
donc la partie a commencé par des cats
donc cavalier 6 c4 c5
voilà donc à ce moment là donc premier
choix psychologique de karpov karpov
décide de jouer cavalier 23 alors on va
déjà voir ce que ce qui se serait passé
si karpov avait joué des cinq là c'est
déjà un moment important
c'est déjà un moment très important
c'est à dire à ce moment là les joueurs
décident sur quel terrain ils vont ils
vont se diriger
donc c'est à dire que dans cette
position si karpov avait joué des cinq
topaloff
donc on va regarder cette ligne topalov
aurait probablement joué b5
donc voilà il aurait probablement joué
b5 qui fait partie de son répertoire et
après b5 donc on imagine la prise du
pion et le pion à 6 donc cette variante
c'est ce qu'on appelle le gambit le
gambit bengo d'accord c'est là que la
ici l'idée des noirs c'est comment
sacrifie d'une un pion pour l'initiative
exactement c'est à dire donc là par
exemple si les blancs prennent le pion à
6 les les noirs vont reprendre avec le
fouet vont se retrouver avec un pion -
mais ils vont avoir la conduire là
là la colonne à d'ouverte et la colonne
b d'ouverte aussi attendait donc la
colonne beidou verte et ils vont mettre
le fou le fou angers7
ouais donc plus tard ils vont mettre ce
fou ici ouais voilà sûr c'est sûr ça
m'agace jet set et se retrouvait avec la
grande diagonale pour le fou donc on
peut dire que dans cette position les
noirs vont avoir beaucoup de
l'initiative d'initiative et ça ça tu
karpov jamais laisser parfois parfois
mais on peut dire que topaloff est le
spécialiste du jeu actif il prouve très
souvent qu'il est capable de grandir de
d'exploiter le désavantage matériel par
l'activité il est capable de compenser
ça il le fait très bien
donc dans cette position karpov a décidé
de jouer prudemment cavaliers f3 donc de
transposer dans une anglaise c'est à
dire on aurait pu très bien obtenir
cette position par un c4
donc après cavaliers f3 donc présents
des quatre cavaliers prend des cats la
autre moment très important
psychologique la partie commence dès les
tous premiers coups en toi c'est de la
psychologie ca qu'elle a bien évidemment
ces champions la connaissent tous mais
ils choisissent en fonction de la
psychologie de l'adversaire et on est
embêté et est exactement c'est à dire à
ce moment là karpov qui jouent contre le
jeune thomas 994 topalov devait avoir
peut-être une vingtaine d'années donc il
le test il le test sur son répertoire
donc on peut dire que dans cette
position karpov veut savoir ce que
topalov à préparer dans cette position
là encore le moment de choisir sa
variante et les noirs ont le choix entre
7,6 et e75 donc e75 est une variante
intéressante donc qui mène à grandir
encore un sacrifice de pions dont
cavaliers ici puis on prend des cinq
puis on prend des 5 c 4 prend des cinq
ça marche
voilà alors là il ya un piège très connu
c'est que sur cavaliers prendre des sacs
qui est très très mauvais les blancs
jouent d'am-dam prend des cinq dames
prend des 5 et cavaliers c'est un
superbe fourchette donc une fourchette
le cavalier attaque le roi et la dame en
d5 et il est blanc gagné une pièce
donc évidemment on ne joue pas des 5 on
est dans cette position en
après peut emprunter 5 on ne prend pas
avec le cavalier on joue faux 6,5 et on
se développe le plus est celle là c'est
pour les initiatives encore une fois
donc actuellement
topalov a changé son répertoire ils
jouent eux 5 c'est toujours utile à
savoir s produit s ancien correspond
mieux à son style donc il s'est trouvé
mais bon on va voir qu'à l'époque
topalov jouer eux six donc dans cette
position on transpose dans une anglaise
typique et karpov commence par g 3g
trois cavaliers c6 est là encore un
autre choix très important
karpov jouf ou g2 ils jouent faux j'ai
deux actuellement la théorie dispose
donc de deux courts principaux fou j'ai
2 et cavaliers c3 et donc karpov a joué
fou g2 et non cavaliers c3 parce que il
n'a pas envie que le fou sur dans cette
position donc on va revenir donc dans
cette position il n'a pas envie de jouer
cavalli c3 probablement parce que après
tout bekkat donc après fouet fuite
bécane
le cavalier se retrouve cloué
quelquefois les blancs les noirs
prennent le cavalier ans et noah et le
pion c est doublé doublé l'a évidemment
comme ça va être sur une colonne ouverte
c'est ce sera embêtant
exactement donc ça c'est une position
très très grande baraque mais mais mais
karpov préfère d'abord mettre son fou
sur la grande diagonale et il se réserve
la possibilité sur fouquet quatre échecs
de jouer donc dans cette ligne de jouets
food et 2 voilà ça c'est la grande idée
de karpov dans cette position donc fou
des deux est par exemple
après les changes de fou voilà donc
après le change de fou il se passe
quelque chose de très important qu'il ne
faut pas négliger donc deux pièces se
sont échangé de foot cases noires et
donc il faut tout de suite regardé ce
que deviennent les cases noires et là on
remarque que le pion 17 qui est arrivée
va probablement avancé sur la case des
six parce que s'ils avancent en d5
probablement et on va se retrouver avec
un pur isolé quelque chose de
désagréable et après 17 des six il n'y a
pas de fous pour défendre ce type y ont
adhéré
donc les blancs qui vont mettre leurs
donc après la casse des six donc dans
cette position de la case des six va
être facile attaqué par une tour sur des
seins en plus une tour qui va aller sur
cette case là
donc après ce petit rock et après le
petit rock évidemment oui parce que
c'est complètement interdite et donc ça
va être beaucoup plus facile pour
exercer une pression sur ce plan des six
d'accord voilà donc ça c'est l'idée
l'idée cachée de karpov pas vraiment
mais en tout cas c'est l'idée principale
mais c'est beaucoup de souplesse à
arrêter quand on regarde son style c'est
pour la semaine des traces ou exercer un
maximum de possibilités possibilité oui
et donc dans cette position topalov a
décidé de jouer fous ces 5 il a décidé
de jouer sous ses cinq donc le cavaliere
revient sur b3 et il revient en recettes
donc poussé 5 c'était probablement pour
excentré le cavalier un petit peu à
l'aise dame
il revient sur recettes et là bon il va
jouer des six son pion sera très très
bien défendu et plus tard il va essayer
éventuellement d'attaqué à l'aide
d'armes pas avait le droit puisque
évidemment on sait très bien que après
petit rock il ne faut pas pousser les
pions de la loi donc fou aux sept
cavaliers c3 petit rock petit rock donc
des coûts de développement tout à fait
classique des six voilà donc des 6es la
foule f4 donc karpov et très très
directe dans cette position c'est à dire
que karpov place sont fous sur la case
f4 et là ils attaquent le pion des six
il attaque le pion des six donc le fou
attaque le plan des six probablement
après il va essayer d'attaquer avec la
colonne ouverte profité de l'hiver pour
attaquer ce pion et en même temps il
fait quelque chose de très important aux
échecs il développe ses pièces
c'est très très très important c'est
très important et donc après avoir
développé toutes ces pièces il pourra
encore attaqué
plus plus violemment se plaint des six
donc on peut se poser la question de
savoir si ce que ce que vaut ce coût de
7,5
donc ça c'est une question importante
savoir ce que vaut l'avancée du pion
l'avancée du pion est très mauvaise
c'est à dire qu'après avoir avancé ses
pions le pion des six sera
définitivement arriver c'est à dire très
peu d'espoirs d'avancées sur cinq est
donc comme le pion pourra plus avancés
sur des sacs ça sera ce qu'on appelle
une faiblesse chronique
c'est à dire que le les problèmes des
noirs ne vont pas s'arranger
donc il faut faire très attention à ses
pions à la structure depuis un centre à
chaque coup de pion aux échecs est très
très important donc dans cette position
on ne peut pas pousser ses pions en plus
après 6 e 5 le la pression exercée sur
la grande diagonale achats à 8 sera
terrible sera terrible les cases
blanches seront complètement prise par
le fou de le fou de cases blanches
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire donc dans
cette position comme en plus on ne peut
pas chasser ce fou par le haut 6e 5
il faut trouver un moyen pour se
débarrasser de ce fou et l'a donc dans
cette position topalov a eu l'idée donc
d'attaquer le fou alors ça c'est un coup
et ça il faut vraiment que tu expliques
ce coup là parce qu'il n'est pas facile
c'est d'abord c'est dans tous les
bouquins pour débutants on dit jamais
joué le cavalier sur le bord de
l'échiquier exactement papa propre pas
protégés donc ça c'est un coût tout à
fait extraordinaire quand même oui je
crois qui secoue de cavaliers donc est
principalement destiné à la volonté des
noirs de prendre ce fou d'accord ils
veulent prendre le four à f4 éliminer ce
fou qui attaquent le une nacelle s'est
donc et probablement si si le four
revient sur e3
les noirs ne sont pas trop inquiétés il
pense que bon probablement c'est pas
c'est beaucoup moins grave d'avoir un
fou sur trois quarts en f4 donc le
cavalier et sur les points mais c'est
pour s'échanger sur le fou contre le fu
hk et f4 donc là les blancs ont joué un
coup très très important ils ont joué
dans cette position que trois ça c'est
un coût tout à fait est là c'est encore
un coup et tout d'un coup c'est un coup
très et en anglais c'est à dire dans
cette position la dame d un attaque le
cavalier h5
ça c'est la chose tactique évidente et
il le faut et d'en fermer ici dans cette
case
mais bon karpov n'a pas envie de bouger
se fout donc ils le donnent donc on va
on va regarder ce qui se passe après
cavaliers prend fou cavelier grand fou
ben ça c'est quand même si je peux me
permettre c'est quand même et alan wass
candy gardons la paire de fou on les
doublants pas les pions surtout pas vers
l'extérieur il fait tout le contraire la
karpov
oui c'est ce qu'on appelle des paradoxes
un petit peu dire c'est bon là c'est de
la haute stratégie donc dans cette
position les blancs ont décidé de donner
la paire de fou ils reprennent en f4 et
l'idée principale donc évidemment c'est
d'ouvrir les lignes donc il va permettre
à ces tours les tours à 1 et les tours à
1 et les tours f1 devenir par exemple
sur des uns et le 1 sur ces deux cases
et après les deux tours vont exercer une
pression terrible sur ses entrées noir
sur les wii sur le centre noir et sur
les colonnes d et sur les colonnes eux
donc voilà donc ça c'est qu'on dira ce
qu'on appelle optimiser son potentiel de
de jeu donc ça c'est une chose
importante
on constate toujours que la grande
diagonale achats à huit est complètement
grandir dominé par le fou j'ai 2 donc on
peut voir que en nombre de cases par
exemple en nombre de cases le centre de
l'échiquier et complète et puissamment
occupée par les blancs dans ce cas
rendre au lac en tout cas pas occuper
mes contrats contrôle et donc c'est une
chose très importante et peut-être que
cette chose mérite mérite un pion doublé
en plus ce plan doublé dans ce cas de
figure là est probablement destinée
aussi à utiliser d'armes ce pion f pour
éventuellement jouer f5 et pourrait
essayer d'attaquer aussi d'attaquer un
petit peu le répulsion jouets qu'ils
s'échangent tout de suite
exactement et de toute façon comme le
pion avance il va se rapprocher du roi
et tout sera possible
donc là dans cette position on peut dire
que les blancs ont un petit avantage et
que de toute façon la paire de fou c'est
le fou le 7 et le fou ses beats qui sent
pas très bon pour l'instant
est ce qu'il faut regarder ce qui est
très important c'est sûr que c'est
d'être très observateur
quand on est d'avoir comment dire
d'augmenter un petit peu son son feeling
un petit peu et dans ce type de position
on peut se dire quand même que le fouet
c'était le fou s'est vite sont assez
passif donc topalov se développe
je vous fous 17 donc là il fait ce qu'on
dira il défend sa garde pour l'instant
dam des deux donc on continue le
développement dame b 8 donc d'amd 8
c'est un coup encore très intéressant
c'est à dire quand la dame bien sûr b8
elle va elle défend toujours le pion des
six épreuves le talon d'achille la
position noir et aussi la dame va aider
les pions noirs à 7 et 17 ans et deux
pions le pion à sète va probablement
venir sur a6 et le pion 17 va venir sur
dessins sur pc pour attaquer le centre
par les flots
exactement terrifiée parce que
finalement le pion le plus central des
blancs 58 ans et quatre exactement
et en plus quand le pion sera sur b5 le
pion b et le plan c peuvent s'échanger
ce qui permettrait aux pions des
d'avancé sur des 5 et d'éliminer qu on
dire de ne plus avoir d'autre ça c'est
le rêve des noirs des pions à rien et ça
c'est assez
c'est le rêve d'évincer disons que c'est
le plan principal dans ce type
d'émission est donc ce qui est aussi
important c'est qu'après on aura donc un
pion contre 2 mais les pressions
exercées par les pièces noires dans ce
cas de figure serait intéressante donc
topalov a envie d'attaquer mais karpov
n'a pas envie donc tu aurais fera donc
touré flanc c'est donc c'est le premier
placement le premier choix de karpov
pour occuper ces colonnes ouverte comme
j'avais expliqué et karpov donc qui au
qui occupe la colonne eux donc à
l'intention dans cette position de jouer
de jouer f4 f5 quand on a des biens
doublé l'idée c'est de s'en débarrasser
il veut son passé alors par exemple
après 75 cl et noir prennent le pion au
f5
donc si les noirs prennent ce ce pion je
ne maîtrise pas très bien donc s'ils
prennent le pion à f/5 karpov pourra
jouer fou j'ai deux grands cavaliers c6
way et après fou prend ses six exemple
il pourra gagner une pièce n'accapare
tour prend 2,7 ce genre de petites
variantes c'est très important dans la
pratique de m exact pas finalement il
n'y a pas besoin de calculer des
variantes très longue mais des choses
simples comme ça qui permettent
d'avancer dans la partie exactement
c'est à dire en place à la fois une
pièce sur une case très très utile
stratégiquement et en même temps il ya
quelques petites pointes tactique et 20
mètres d'avancé qui permettent et qui
force l'adversaire à
à s'occuper de ces points tactiques de
dire l'adversaire au lieu de placer ce
qu'on appelle en anglais le set up
c'est à dire le type de position
défensive idéal doivent s'occuper de
petit point tactique donc c'est ce que
fait car c'est ce que fait topalov dans
cette position comme la menace directe
cf 4 5
topalov joue g6 mais j'ai si ça c'est
pas avant pourquoi
oui j'ai si c'est pas bon parce que
c'est un affaiblissement
ouais les noirs commencent à s'affaiblir
c'est à dire quand on pousse les pions
devant le roi toujours des décisions
très très dur c'est à dire jeu les
joueurs du top niveau en général comme
je l'expliquais calcul très très bien
c'est clair mais aussi ils font beaucoup
confiance à l'heure alors feeling et
quand il touche à un pion de leurs
droits ils passent en général beaucoup
beaucoup de temps pour être convaincu
pour pour se dire bon dans cette
position j'ai pas d'autres possibilités
il faut le faire oui mais ça c'est une
question une question de débutants mais
c'est une constance souvent c'est à dire
l'avantagent de pouce à un pion du roi
c'est avec les maths du couloir
ça évite le mode du conte barbas 1 on
est d'accord c'est quand même un des
premiers matches quand on apprend et
puis qu'on place donc quelquefois c'est
bon quelquefois c'est bon mais de toute
façon quand on a besoin de le faire même
pour éviter le maître du couloir souvent
bon souvent c'est le plonger et le plus
rage qu'on pousse c'est rarement le pion
f
et souvent on se dit lequel pousser un
accord vraiment à se pose beaucoup de
questions il faut rester au sec beaucoup
de questions exactement c'est une des
choses les plus importantes à maîtriser
donc à ce jeu quoi donc savoir affaiblir
sans moi dans les moments importants
enfin disons que savoir à combien sera
c'est pas c'est pas le terme exact
puisque à affaiblir c'est ça correspond
pas à ce qu'on voudrait faire à au roi
puisque le roi c'est un jeu toucher à
ses pions du roi sans trop la faible et
exactement ce serait peut-être
le terme précis alors là alors là dans
cette position les blancs ont joué h4
ils ont joué h4 et ça c'est ce qu'on
appelle enfin ce que moi j'appelle une
sorte de mondialisation du conflit c'est
à dire dans cette position les blancs
commencent à exercer une pression donc
sur des la dame en d2 sur la colonne des
voix là sur la colonne eux et maintenant
il faut chercher un nouveau terrain un
nouveau terrain donc poussé allal el
dames c'est pas vraiment ce qu'ils
recherchent les noirs ont commencé à
s'affaiblir donc il faut commencer à
trouver d'autres secteurs de jeu quand
on joue à acheter h4 on a envie de
préparer h 4 h 5 donc h5
et là évidemment la présence avait
complètement on regarde même pas 1 mètre
regarde même pas ça non même pas jamais
on a tout à l'heure on a droit de se
faire doubler les pions comme karpov
mais la g prend à chaque ça se regarde
sans qu'un pion doublé en face du roi le
roi complètement dénudée si je puis dire
c'est hors de question donc la menace h5
c'est donc plus pour par exemple prendre
en g6 et changer le pion donc une fois
qu' on enrage 5
on va prendre le pian angers 6 le pion à
vii va probablement reprendre et pas le
pion f puisque le pion f7 soutient le
plan du sens donc et après avoir échangé
ses deux pions le roi noir sera un petit
peu plus affaiblie donc évidemment tu
peux me poser la question oui mais le
roi blanc
et peut-être affaibli si on touche si on
pousse à un pion un pion de sang par
exemple c'est une question ces questions
mais ce qui se passe c'est que dans
cette position le roi blanc en réalité
est très bien protégé il est très bien
protégé déjà on compte le nombre de
pions qui sont sur le roc blanc
il y en a quatre sur le roc noir il y en
a trois le nombre de pièces qui sont sur
wat blanc et en a une en fou et une tour
mais la tour ne protège pas du tout le
roi noir dans cette position le fou par
contre qui contrôle toutes les cases
blanches des alentours et très très
utile donc les blancs peuvent
tranquillement pousser leurs pions h
ayant davantage l'espace quand même qui
leur permet juste un an exactement
et puis quand je vais parler de
mondialisation c'est à dire on a créé un
secteur faible donc le secteur faible
c'est le centre les colonnes d et e
donc les pièces noires sont forcés plus
ou moins de défendre sa et d'essayer de
trouver du contre je donc la dame b 8 et
peut-être la torah 8 plus tard et comme
c'est qu'elle s'en occuper c'est le
moment d'interrogation à réallon
adhérents exactement c'est le monde
intervenir dans un autre secteur
donc ça c'est ce que font tous les
grands stratèges et donc cela se
séparent fait donc dans cette position
topalov ne veut pas toucher à ses pions
et il décide donc de d'essayer de
contrer un petit peu le jeu de karpov
il joue à six lui s'en fiche à lui de
toute façon finalement la meilleure
contre attaque c'est d'aller de l'autre
côté bruno bazi la confiance il faut
avoir confiance situation hélas pas
tellement le choix
il a confiance et peut-être qu'il n'a
pas le choix il se dit que de toute
façon s'il arrive à ouvrir la position à
led dame
il aura peut-être la possibilité
d'occuper un petit peu les pièces de
karpov allèles dame est donc
peut-être que karpov sera un peu plus
gentil à les lois mais malheureusement
ce n'est pas le cas car peuvent pour
l'instant ignore alors oui ça c'est très
important aussi c'est que souvent en
échec les joueurs doivent faire
confiance doivent suivre un plan
jusqu'au bout donc peu importe la
situation
c'est pas parce que les blancs ont
commencé à pousser ici que les noirs
doivent réagir ici dans cette position
il faut qu'ils sentent quel est
l'endroit de l'échiquier où ils peuvent
optimiser leur leur jeu de pièces et
donc s'en soucie enfin en se souciant
mais ils doivent toujours penser à leurs
plans il faut toujours suivre une
direction donc h5 et là dans cette
position après h5 b5
voilà le jour contre attaque h projet 6
voilà donc karpov a affaibli le roi est
là quelque chose de très très beaux dans
cette position c'est que bon s'il prend
des cinq pions prend les noirs vont
contrôler bien centré vont peut-être
s'en tirer mais là karpov a joué
cavalier 6,5 cavalli c5 sa transe
transforme tout donc là il transforme la
position va voir un petit peu là
exactement dont on comprend on prend
cavagnan c5 ac et la dame prend le fou
en 17
voilà donc il n'y a plus de pions il n'y
a plus de pions arriérés en 1 6 mais la
dame a réussi à pénétrer dans les lignes
le fou est de plus en plus puissant sur
la grande diagonale et le cavalier sait
si cette attaque et donc il faut le
défendre par tour ses 8 est là karpov
gentiment
me convenir on pourrait presque dire
empalé les pièces noires sur ces trois
cases les pièces lourdes qui conçoivent
le casser les plus puissantes et donc
maintenant il va complètement travailler
travailler même très très violemment à
l'aiea les droits et ils jouent tout
reprend aussi ce jeu tout reproche très
jolie donc la très rapidement il a pris
l'avantagé maintenant c'est une
situation tactique très jolie qui va
nous commenter exactement
oui donc maintenant donc l'avantagent
positionnait l'état qui les pièces
blanches sont très très active mais bon
il faut pas il faut pas traîner parce
que les noirs vont probablement chauffer
la dame
donc il faut transformer il faut
transformer cet avantage stratégique en
disant quelque chose d'un peu plus
tactique et il faut profiter finalement
de ce que les pièces noires soient
complètement occupé ailleurs pour pour
attaquer le roi alors là excusez moi je
te pose des questions il faut être
violent au début tu nous donnes des
conseils stratégiques mais là il faut
calculer quand même un petit peu
ah oui là évidemment ça c'est la force
du choc des champions c'est à dire être
précis dans les calculs et tout et en
même temps ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que le calcul est important mais il y a
aussi le encore même à ce niveau là il
ya encore le feeling c'est à dire dans
cette position on a confiance dans ce
type de course c'est à dire les joueurs
sont tellement entraîné à part leur
éducation
probablement par des exercices qu'ils
ont fait quand il était jeune et tout ça
ils sont entraînés à avoir des notions
abstraites du jeu d'échecs
ils savent faire la différence entre
entre la valeur des pièces et
quelquefois le type de position donc là
les noirs ont joué tour à cette voie là
pour attaquer la dame
donc c'est très embêtant c'est votre foi
en des temps si l'aide d'un bouchon va
prendre la tour et tout donc la carte
offre encore jouer un coup de tonnerre
badaboum quoi un voyage exactement veut
pas perdre de temps donc plus on prend
pions projet 6 et d'un échec
voilà donc là maintenant cette position
comment le roi va t-il se sortir de tout
ça le roi bien sûr j'ai cette voie là il
vient sur gsm / f 8 c'est probablement
très dangereux probablement à cause
d'eux
d5 et des possibilités de maths en g8
donc il vit à angers 7 c'est la casa
plus sûr actuellement est dans cette
position après s'être karpov joue fou
prend ses 6 ans récupère quand même les
matériels
on a beau attaquer fo oui il faut quand
je disais nous sur abstraite c'est quand
même pas c'est pas des fantasmes il faut
quand même faire des choses très
concrètes à ce jeu donc france et 6 et
l'a donc topalov essaye de revenir dans
l'action avec ses pièces selon ton tour
des huit qui éventuellement pourra venir
sur la garde des six pour faire une
fourchette entre la dame e6 et le fou
c'est 6 voilà donc après tour des huit
karpov prend le plan b 5
donc là si on compte le matériel donc
karpov à un cavalier est par exemple si
je vais prendre deux des pions au hasard
je prendre celui ci celui ci est celui
ci donc il a un cavalier et trois pions
contre une tour donc c'est quand même un
peu mieux pour les finalement pour les
bleus finalement c'est ce qu'on sait
moins chers comme attaque
pour l'instant c'est pas cher oui c'est
pas cher mais par contre actuellement il
a perdu un petit peu d'initiatives quand
on prend un pion on permet aux pièces
nord de se dynamiser ce que profite
topalov il met son fonds sur les comptes
des gones a maintenant il essaye de un
petit peu de d'activer ces pièces donc
il a activé sa tour il active sont fous
et sept tours menace éventuellement
devenir sur cette case donc la
maintenance et au panaf qui a
l'initiative qui avait lieu quatre
attaques le fou fou des quatre puisque
le foot est en prison pure prend 1,6
donc il continue à prendre les pions et
là dans cette position après prise si on
récupère pas de matériel avec les noirs
enfin si on gagne pas quelque chose ça
va être très très dur donc d'un v6 d'un
v6 ça al'avantage de clouer le fou c6 le
foncier si tu ne peux pas bouger puisque
à la dame derrière et donc dans cette
position on veut essayer de gagner une
pièce et la karpov a joué un coup
fantastique
il oublie complètement son courage il
joue tour d un donc topalov prend le
pion à 6 la dame peut rentrer dans le
jeu le fou c6 est cloué
les noirs commencent à s'activer très
très en dedans et là que la combinaison
final la combinaison final donc dans
cette position qui reporte à jouer tout
reprend des cats
alors tout reprend des cartes c'est
encore un coup très très tactique mais
en même temps très stratégique
c'est à dire dans cette position il
prend le contrôle des cases noires donc
le fou de cases blanches il à la dame
qui pourrait contrôler les cases noires
donc il prend le contrôle de toutes les
cases qui sont autour du roi
donc on va voir comment ce comment il a
réussi à transformer cet avantage donc
tout reprend des cats damev six échecs
droit g8
oprean un pion échec échec maintenant
allez vas-y et cher roger cet échec
roger huit cavaliers 6 donc c'est vrai
pour cette position il a un duo fou
cavaliers qui est terrible et qui vouent
les deux qualités contre à droite où non
exactes un sac d et les joueurs tchèques
d'encre wife cette fouille 8,3 et fuite
d'après ces cinq bons donc là il prend
un pion il ya des tours emprise et ou
d'anne decis pour défendre les tours
dame prend 1,7 donc il a quand même
réussi à récupérer une qualité d'âme pro
m6 est maintenant dans cette position
karpov n'a plus qu'à revenir vers son
roi avec le fou tour des deux baies 3
tours b2i roi g2 donc finalement la
position finale
ce qui est important c'est qu'il ya plus
besoin d'avoir de menaces tactique le
roi a très bien défendu
c'est à dire la kf2 et contrôlé par la
damas est le fou va revenir sur la kf3
et là ça devient technique est dans
cette position
la suite est très simple après après le
matériel compte c'est à dire les pions
qui sont en plus mais le fauve au 3 mai
il y a
cinq pièces à 8 contre 5 on trouve ça
c'est largement super hélas topalov
comme la partie est très jolie d'ici
d'abandonner bon en 10 secondes
une conclusion parce que finalement tout
ça est passionnant et il faut vous faut
quand même beaucoup de temps pour
l'expliquer alors j'en ai qu'une
conclusion de cette partie une
conclusion de cette partie basse et que
de toute façon
le grandir il faut il faut faire
confiance un petit peu à la position il
faut il faut savoir sentir les points
les points sensibles de la position et
il ne faut pas hésiter quand on allie si
l'initiative de trouver le coup candidat
le plus le plus opportun dont classe par
exemple c'était fou et 4 qui était une
décision importante cavaliers c5 qui
était également une décision importante
et il faut il faut également être précis
dans l'est dans les choix tactiques et
dont le dénouement
merci au revoir à la semaine prochaine
oh